tonight we separate the weak from the
strong if you don't make it through
tonight you're dead to all of them
rooster light the torch nice headband
that's why that's why at rustle playing
a fraternity pledge master in 22 Jump
Street born into an acting family
Russell took a different path and spent
several years pursuing a professional
hockey career until an injury shifted
his focus to Hollywood now he stars as
dud in the AMC show lodged 49 it follows
the former surfer as he tries to rebuild
his life after the death of his father
and the loss of his family pool cleaning
business in season two a new family
takes over his former shop and dud tries
to get a job there actually I'm glad
you're here because I wanted to come in
introduce myself and if you don't mind
offer my services services yeah
inventory of main ins installation and
got it all wired yeah you know I'd be
happy to come on offer myself as a
consultant and when I get off please
jump back in I don't know vehicle right
now but I do know every pole from La
Salle the Lakewood so oh this is our son
Bowie that's his job hi Bowie Wyatt
Russell joins us now good morning Wyatt
lad 49 has been described as
ridiculously hard to synopsize yes so
how would you describe the show yeah I
would describe the show is sort of an
existential journey of my character dud
going from one point A to point B and
point a to point b being Nirvana which
is a very simple place cleaning pools
but you have to jump through fire and
inhale they get there so I was thinking
so I was thinking why sort of like magic
too mundane yes does that make sense to
you yes you look at your dead character
yes what dud sees is in everyday life
you can choose to see magic and anything
yeah it walked down the street and you
can you can the way anything the way a
building is built the the way anybody
presents themselves in certain ways it's
all part of the world were living in
look what's happened to him he's had a
snake bite shark attack his father's
dead yet he is still an optimist yes and
still really believes in life and it
appears to be searching for the meaning
of life - yeah it does an eternal
optimist they're happy when it comes
around he sees in a light of positivity
and he tries to see through through
anything negative is not part of of what
he wants to be about he's trying to look
at the positive things in life even even
through death and through the hard
experience the lodge that he joins the
social club yeah how does that help him
that everybody's looking for a place to
become a part of something and in our
world today especially with phones and
email and internet in whatever you don't
have face-to-face contact like you used
to have and these lodges represent a
place where people can go and they can
share their experiences whether they're
they're their failures or triumphs and
they can be together and that's what
that's what it is you seem to be a fan
of face to face contact over the digital
alternative you're not on social media
no now doing that these days that's
taking a stance whether you want to or
not do you want to or you turns out a
message there no no no it's it's
literally just I don't engage with it
yeah that well I it's it's it's I'm a
private person it's sort of the last
bastion of privacy you know way I know
man missing out on money or spot
whatever but it's just I find it it's
nice I don't to worry about it I don't
worry about what other people think or
what I say or it's not I don't did you
dabble in it and then get off no I well
when it first came out it was all
private yeah roll it in neutral and you
could see I thought it was cool cuz it
and I'm on it but I'm privately so you
can be with your friends you can see
what your friends are doing but I don't
really love the idea of some of the New
Jersey feeling like whatever I do is
somehow impacting their day to do with
their day yeah just there weighing in on
your life exactly
I remember you when you were playing
hockey there were a lot of stories in
the news because apparently you were
very good at it but then you were
injured do you think if you hadn't been
injured you'd still be playing hockey to
this day I wouldn't love it yeah yeah it
was my life and my passion but I've been
and I would I would have and it would
have been a real mistake because it's
like it's a drug it keeps you going back
where you're gonna go to some new
country and you know Norway and play in
some weird town and and it's gonna be
great but then you realize you come back
home and all of a sudden you're 36 years
old that you have no marketable so you
glad in a way you're glad you got
injured I am in hindsight it was the
best thing that ever happened to me for
sure because because because because I
wouldn't have my view of life was rather
narrow it wasn't I was I was
experiencing life in another country in
other countries and that was great but
but my view was narrow in terms of what
I was going to be able to do and give in
my life but acting on it but acting is
so low and hockey as a team the
difference between the two the lessons
you learn with that I think it's
interesting well I think that with the
thing that the lessons that were that
were similar that acting although it
seems so low is actually very
team-oriented you know I find that
people that have do it and do it on a
high level that I've worked with all are
very inclusive with with the crew with
the people around you to me they're all
there to make you look good yes right
and the thing about about competition
and sports and hockey and acting is that
in in hockey people there's another
person on the other side of that of you
trying to make you not win that wants
you to lose yeah and then acting
everybody wants you to be good yeah no
one ever goes through a movie and it's
like I hope this guy's horrible people
media that root against the mental
health of all I did it thank you for
being here yes and thank you for not
talking on and on about your mom and
your dad yeah why Russell very white
rose ain't you